hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Caroll I
don't know how many of you remember or
have this recollection but back in the
early days of like blogging and social
media there was this question of whether
or not there was still a place for
science journalism in the world since
after all you had scientists who could
now just start up their blog and talk
about whatever it is they wanted to do
and the answer is yes you still do need
science journalists and you need
political journalists and legal
journalists and economic journalists you
need journalists who are experts in what
they're doing if only because
professional journalists have an
obligation to be fair to think about
everything that is going on in the field
they're covering and explain it to the
people who are reading or watching or
listening in an unbiased overarchingly
Fair Way whereas the individual
researchers they're going to talk about
what they personally think is cool so in
fact I think you need both it's great to
have professional researchers being able
to reach broad audiences in uh whatever
way they can you also need professional
journalists to set a wider stage and
make sure that nothing Falls between the
cracks so I say this because I'm a
person who is a professional researcher
but I also have you know public Outreach
public facing aspects of what I do
including this podcast mindscape and I
have uh we spot for speculative big
picture conceptual kinds of things right
the origin of the universe the nature of
Life what intelligence or complexity are
the foundations of quantum mechanics
stuff like that and I say this because I
hope people don't get the impression
that most of science is like that
because it really isn't I happen to be
interested in that stuff but most of
Science and really really good important
fun exciting parts of science science
are much more grounded right they're
much more close to the data to known
laws of physics you can know the
fundamental laws of physics and that
still leaves an enormous amount unknown
in terms of how those laws play out
whether it's in biology or for that
matter in nuclear astrophysics and
that's what we're talking about today
nuclear astrophysics you might wonder
what the intersection of those two words
is astrophysics of course the whole
universe Stars galaxies Etc well where
did those nuclei come from that make up
the heavier elements that make up you
and me and the Earth and things like
that from astrophysics from Stars mostly
but as we will see not only from Stars
so our guest today is sanjina Curtis who
is an astrophysicist that UC see
Berkeley and she is the nuclear
astrophysicist she studies how heavier
elements are created in Stellar
explosions and other environments in the
universe she's also extremely effective
as an Outreach communication person she
started a new Tik Tok series believe it
or not I can't do this I'm too old for
that but sanina is is hip to what the
kids like these days and she started a
series called Stardust that in little
tiny Tik Tok videos but very carefully
produced explains the principles of
nuclear astrophysics and because it's
fun and cool goes into how those
elements that you make in the Stars show
up in different ways here on Earth so
you can hear about uh biology you can
hear about archaeology you can hear
about all sorts of fun things that these
nuclei end up in here on Earth as I said
in very grounded scientific contexts and
I have to say as someone who was an
undergraduate and graduate student in
astronomy nuclear astrophysics is super
cool you know the story of how all of
the elements in the periodic table get
to be made over the history of the
universe is almost suspiciously Rich you
know you you might think if you were
thinking like a physicist that there was
a mechanism that made all the elements
you know maybe 99% of them and then
there was some little tiny things but
but that's not how it actually is there
are many different
channels different mechanisms in the
universe from The Big Bang to cosmic
rays to Supernova and more that all are
important for explaining where the
different elements in the periodic table
came from so this is a little bit of a
journey through real world astrophysics
real world in the sense that we have
data and are testing our theories but
not that we know all the answers yet as
you'll see there's some good questions
still remaining so let's
[Music]
go sanina Curtis Welcome to the wicap
podcast thank you I'm really excited to
be here Sean as I just said as we were
talking before this is one of the rare
Pleasures for me where I get to sorry
mindscape fans I know this is audio only
to you but a very cute kitty cat just
walked in front of San here and the in
the video so we get cat cinnamon she has
to make an appearance at these things
whenever my cats are in the back on the
floor my my my two cats are very
groundbased cats they do not jump up uh
very easily so anyway uh as I was saying
uh this is a happy occasion for me
because we get to talk about something I
know a little bit about but I will you
know try to channel the people who don't
know anything about it so let's start
super duper simple we're interested in
how elements are made um what are these
elements of which you speak tell us a
little bit about the periodic table how
it works how we should think we've all
seen it but you know how should we
conceptualize it how should we look at
it and get things out of it right so uh
the period ICT table all the 118 I
believe elements the origin of those
elements is what we're interested in the
field of nuclear astrophysics and the
way I think about it usually is in terms
of the astrophysical sites that operated
and created new nuclei and how sort of
the periodic table builds up as a result
of those uh astrophysical uh nuclear
reactions at in various astrophysical
sites and so for example you have the
lighter elements hydrogen and helium
there's a particular type of
nucleosynthesis that produces those and
then when you're looking at things like
carbon and oxygen elements that are
essential to life there's really stars
that are doing nuclear reactions to make
those and then you start thinking about
the iron group of elements so iron and
copper and zinc and there you need
really energetic Supernova explosions
and then you go even heavier and there's
even less of those elements uh generally
speaking in the universe and things like
gold are precious elements come from an
entirely different type of
nucleosynthesis site so in my mind I
think of the periodic table in terms of
the different astrophysical processes
and sites that have built it up that's
great and just to be super duper clear
nuclear astrophysics being your central
concern means that you don't actually
care about atoms it's it's just the
nuclei that matter to you I mean the
periodic table is organized on the basis
of the chemical structure and you're not
you're not into the whole chemical thing
no not so much so the second molecules
begin to matter uh that's not really my
realm of interest of course I'm
interested in it as any human being is
and as chemists are in terms of the
properties of the atoms themselves and
you know where you have metals and
non-metals and noble gases and
metalloids so uh the the various Columns
of the periodic table tend to share
certain properties things like that
that's not really uh my research my
research is more about how these
elements came to exist at all exactly
right and there's a long-standing joke
among non- asron how astronomers count
Elements by going hydrogen helium
Metals but but you don't get to do that
right anything than than helium is a
metal for most
astronomers yes that's exactly correct
that's just how we think of uh uh
metallicity which is a quantity it's
just the amount of metals and it's just
anything that's not hydrogen or helium
is is a metal to me I'm sure cths are
not a fan of this kind of nomenclature
and I completely sympathize the other
thing just to get our audience on the on
the right uh wavelength here I bet a lot
of people think that the you universe is
almost all hydrogen or maybe almost all
helium I mean how much do the other
elements the metals Etc matter to the
evolution of the universe in terms of
stars galaxies BL up things oh they they
matter quite a lot Ian it is correct to
say that most of uh uh the stuff in the
universe uh the bionic matter anyway
it's hydrogen and helium um but but the
way uh stars form and then explode and
injects energy as well as new elements
really shapes how galaxies evolve uh
just by changing the properties of the
material that you're looking at um and
also the energetics so a supernova can
can shove material out of a galaxy even
potentially and so it really matters in
terms of when you're starting to think
of the nuclear history of the universe
uh how structures formed it really
matters matters stars formed and
interacted with everything and the
feedback of I I bet that a lot of how we
get an image of the universe comes from
the pictures that we get of it and
they're still pictures generally right
which makes sense because the time scale
in which these things happen the time
scale which a Galaxy effectively evolves
is much longer than a human lifetime but
it does evolve and I think maybe this is
an important thing to get across that if
you took a time lapse of a Galaxy which
we can't do but if you did there'd be
all sorts of churning and exploding and
interesting things happening yeah so
there's actually this field called
Galactic
archaeology um and so you can almost
think of astronomers as
archaeologists uh as we look at older
and older stars or older galaxies we can
kind of get snapshots of what was going
on uh a long time back in the universe
and then we come to present day and the
solar system itself okay well let's do
exactly that then I think that we can
start at the Big Bang um tell us a
little bit as a nuclear astrophysicist
how do you think about the whole phrase
the Big Bang in its
aftermath yeah so as a nuclear
astrophysicist uh the part of the big
bang that I begin to get interested in
is once the Big Bang has occurred and
now the universe has mostly quarks and
gluons and as it expands and cools
neutrons and protons begin to cond out
and of course there's a lot of nuclear
reactions happening and a lot of it
depends on the temperatures and the way
radiation is interacting with the matter
but uh sort of broadest Strokes you have
neutrons and protons beginning to
condense out very short time scale after
the Big B and then you end up with a
certain fraction of neutrons versus
protons and this kind of thing is
important for what kind of elements you
can make but basically maybe seconds
after the big bang or so the elements
that are produced are hydrogen helium
Teensy bit of lithium so this is all
that really comes out of big bang
nucleosynthesis and now you have a
universe full of hydrogen and helium and
then we can begin to form stars out of
and then that's the portion that's where
my active research uh area is is uh
basically stars and Supernova and the
aftermath of those yeah so it's kind of
an interesting race as I understand it
because if you have a hot but not too
hot box of of plasma you would like to
make iron right isn't that the uh the
curve of binding energy maybe maybe fill
us in that story yeah yeah so um the The
Binding energy really wants uh wants
everything to be Iron 56 um however um
the the big bang nucleus synthesis okay
the the temperatures and the densities
that exist exist during uh big bang
nuclear synthesis are not conducive to
having this whole set of nuclei being
produced and also there's a funny thing
where there's a gap in stable nuclei um
so it's very difficult for Big Bang
nuclear synthesis to produce lithium
bellium and Boron so these three
elements don't really well there's a
tiny bit of lithium but uh there's a gap
there where there's not a lot of stable
isotopes uh that you can get at uh in
the nuclear reactions that are possible
to occur in Big Bang nucleosynthesis so
what needs to happen really is you want
to be fusing all this helium that you've
made to make carbon but to do that you
really need the conditions that exist in
Stars I think I remember that George
Gamal and his friends when they were
inventing big bag nucleo synthesis
really hoped that they were going to be
making be able to make the entire
periodic table but basically the
universe just expands too fast and cools
off and there's not enough time for the
reactions to happen exactly yeah yeah so
I mean the reaction rates uh and and
even making the carbon uh in stars that
had to be really figured out to get to
the uh correct state of burum um you
need to hit enough you need to fuse two
hydrogen uh helium nuclei to make
barilan and then you need to hit it with
another their helium to get to carbon
and so then uh it's a very uh sensitive
thing where you need to have enough
verillium that's not decayed away um and
still have uh have a reaction rate that
gets you that carbon because it is very
intricately connected to the specifics
of nuclei and how heavy they are because
you can't just take a helium and add one
more proton to it and one more proton to
it and one more proton to it no no so
yeah I mean you can add a proton to the
helium but then what you end up with is
an unstable isotope of maybe berium is
that and then it very quickly will Decay
away and so there's nothing uh uh
nothing that you can really do with that
so you're stuck coming out of the big
bang with a bunch of hydrogen and helium
and and then I guess you make stars so
is when I was in graduate school which
was a long time ago the whole process by
which stars were made was still pretty
murky I think in the minds of
astrophysicists and and interestingly in
the late Universe it does seem to care
about the existence of heavier elements
they're very useful for making Stars so
how does that even happen do we know how
you make stars in the the first
generation where it's just hydrogen and
helium that's a really interesting topic
but it it is similar to what you said
where we don't really have a clear
answer yet so for example something that
you might call the initial nass function
of the first Stars meaning uh if you
were to bend these Stars by mass how
much uh how many stars have like 10
times the mass of the Sun or how many of
them have 100 times of the mass of the
Sun um and people have done uh and this
is a uh sort of broad Strokes knowledge
that I've gain from Reading other
people's favors um is uh if you do these
simulations and yes metals are important
for cooling and uh the way things evolve
there are different predictions for what
should happen so some people think that
you might end up with stars that are
hundreds of times the mass of the Sun
and those Stars will undergo um not core
collapse supern noi which I study but
something called PA and stability supern
noi um and then uh those particular
supern noi have a very specific
nucleosynthetic signature or you you
might you might end up with low mass
stars as well so it's it's really not
very clear what the masses of these
stars are going to be um when you form
the first generation of stars and Ne nor
have we observed a star that's a
population three star right astronomers
count Stars backwards so the population
three is the first population logically
right yes they count from us you know it
makes sense they count from the present
day they count back backwards so I know
that some people like Katie free have
suggested that dark matter actually
plays a big role in forming that first
generation of stars I have no idea
whether that's plausible or not uh I
guess it it would have to do with the
way um G like the Halos form and then
the galaxies are born in those Halos and
so I'm sure there's an interplay but I
am not sure how that goes I don't think
anyone is okay that's fair okay so we
get some Stars uh um do we at least know
when like how many years after the big
bang that first generation really comes
to life there were Dark Ages right yeah
the Dark Ages and then there's this epic
of
reionization I don't know if I have the
number off the top of my head Z
something long time after hon a long
time after the first minute when we did
Big Bang nuclear synthesis there's a
long long stretch of the Dark Ages yes
and then stars form yeah and then now we
can make the heavier elements right I
mean so the short lesson here uh if if
people going to stop listening right now
most of the elements are made in Stars
not in the Big Bang and there's some
miscellaneous ones made by even cooler
mechanisms but it's Stars doing most of
the work for anything heavier than
helium that's right stars and uh even
Stellar corpses so neutron stars um are
doing the rest of the work okay so
what's the first thing that happens in
the newly stelliferous universe that
that uh spurts heavier elements out
there into the cosmos ah the first thing
that happens I mean one one could argue
it's these par and stability Supernova
so what does that mean a parent
stability Supernova okay so the parent
stability Supernova basically um stars
hundreds of times the mass of the Sun
where in their core the conditions are
such that you can reach a regime where
runaway pair production basically begins
to happen and so pair production meaning
that uh you have electrons and positrons
colliding together to make
gamas um and that reduces um U the
radiation pressure and so it goes uh
sorry when the G gamma ray Collide to
also do the opposite reaction that
reduces the radiation pressure uh in the
core of the star and the radiation
pressure is what's keeping it up um and
so when this paent stability is
encountered the core of the star begins
to uh basically lose all support and it
will trigger nuclear reactions as it
collapses and the whole star blows up
this is kind of fascinating like I I'm
going to confess right here to all the
millions or hundreds of millions of
mindscape listeners I did not really
know about this kind of super noova so
you have a big star much much bigger
than the Sun and it's held up by
radiation pressure so literally the
photons that are being made inside are
keeping up the star and it gets so
intense that the photons start bumping
into each other and making electron
positron pairs lowers the pressure and
the star collapses uh yes and and the
star collapses and then uh as the
temperatures and densities rise you get
nuclear reactions happening and that
kind of under goes a runaway because the
star continues to collapse so the the
pair instability has nothing to do with
the star splitting into two it's uh
Gamay it's photons making pairs yeah
yeah yeah and is this we we've heard of
things like type 1 type 2 Supernova and
things like that is this one of those
this is a separate category sep so this
is a a type of supernova that's kind of
a
theoretical uh a very theoretically
motivated Supernova but uh to my
knowledge we have not observed a
supernova light curve that we might say
look this is a parent stability
Supernova um these explosions are meant
to be very very energetic
and so it could be that they produce a
particular class of supern called super
luminous supern MH um and so they're
they're as the name suggests way more
luminous than your standard type one
type two
Supernova okay cool I feel littleit L
bad now yeah um and the latest kind of
uh thing on that is people look for
signatures of nucleosynthesis in these
parent stability Supernova in Old stars
to kind of show that they might have
occurred um so it's it's something
that's not been observed yet but from
the theory side has a strong motivation
that should exist and is the general
idea that when these stars explode and
uh populate the region around them with
heavier elements were those heavier
elements already there having been um
created in the center of the star and
they're just being mixed into the
environment or are they actually being
created in the explosion yeah so they
are being created in the explosion um as
well as there's some material that uh
some of the elements were already
created during the life of the star so
um in a supernova uh what comes out is a
mixture of what we would call the
hydrostatic nucleosynthesis so
nucleosynthesis that happened when the
star was happily fusing hydrogen to
helium to carbon to oxygen and then uh
explosive nucleus synthesis so really um
elements that were produced during the
explosion Itself by say explosively
burning oxygen to Silicon burning being
here used in a very loose sense the
nuclear nuclear
reaction okay so I that that was a very
helpful to me discussion of the parent
stability Supernova but they're not the
most common ones like you said so what
what are the kinds of supernova
explosions that are really doing the
heavy lifting uh
metal wise right so uh the core collap
supery uh are one of the big ones and
especially early in the history of the
Universe um corcap supern noi are
explosive deaths of stars that are uh 10
more than 10ish times the mass of our
sun and so these stars are able to fuse
uh hydrogen to helium to carbon to
oxygen all the way to making an iron
core and as you touched before because
of the binding energy of iron um it's no
longer uh possible to fuse iron to
generate energy and keep the core of the
star um uh stable right and so then um
they the once the iron core grows to a
certain Mass the core begins to collapse
and there's a whole sequence of a
complicated sequence of events that
occurs for this collapse to turn into an
explosion um of the star and so those
are core collap super rui uh they're
also um so if people are familiar with
the observational categories of type one
and type two um uh type 1 B and C as
well as type 2 supern noi are core
collapse superi oh that's very messy so
just we'll get to them later but you got
to fill in what type 1 a is oh yes so
then the type 1 A's are basically um
very interesting uh explosions of white
works I'm saying this very carefully
because one of the things that uh we
don't know for sure is um the progenitor
systems of type 1 a supern noi so is it
a it's some sort of an explosion of a
white dwarf but it what is is it a
chander Shaker Mass white dwarf or is it
a sub chander Shaker Mass white dwarf um
there's some sort of binary here where
the white dwarf uh is either merging
with another white dwarf to create uh
this thermonuclear explosion that's
really the dis the distinction is it's a
thermonuclear explosion um and then uh
or is it some sort of main sequence star
that's the companion of the white dwarf
that it's accreting material from and
then that's triggering a runaway Thon
nuclear reaction of the white dwarf so
uh the progenitor of uh of these has
been sort of an open question and many
people have many ideas on how exactly
the Stars blow up and what exactly is
the binary that we're looking at and
among other reasons the reason why we
need to understand this is because these
type 1A Supernova were the first
evidence for dark energy that's right
the trying to constrain the expansion
rate of the universe uh relies on on is
it the Philips relation I believe that's
right how you can standardize the light
curves of typ one supern noi
yeah I I think this is since I was an
astronomy undergraduate and graduate
student I'm I've seen this up close but
it's kind of miraculous to me that we
can say so many true things about these
systems in the universe without truly
knowing what they are or what's going on
right I know it's it's a bit unnerving
but it's also
amazing okay so I think we'll get back
to the type 1A Supernova the the white
dwarfs exploding but but let's say more
about the core collapse Supernova I
think I'm going to guess roughly that
this is what most people have in the
back of the Minds when they think of a
supernova it's sort of right used up all
its fuel it collapsed and then it
bounces and then what happens there's a
lot of nuclear reactions going on it's
it's it's a very intricate thing I mean
uh this is full employment for people
like you yeah yeah lots of nuclear
reactions going on a lot of uh Nuclear
Physics going on even with particles
like
neutrinos um and so it is it is truly
messy but that's kind of the fun of it
too um so the the general uh sort of
schematic picture um is that the iron
core begins to collapse uh however it
does not collapse uh indefinitely so at
some point uh you hit very very high
densities nuclear densities in the core
as the core collapse proceeds and around
this point um the repulsive part of the
strong nuclear force kicks in and it
sort of um tried to stop the collapse
and what happens as a result is uh the
portion of the core begins to turn into
a neutron star and it finds a new stable
configuration and so it sort of goes
back into this sort of stable
configuration that results in a bounce
shock what is what you would call and
that bounce shock begins to go through
the rest of the iron core and kind of um
goes out and out and it it's breaking up
uh the iron that's already been created
during this the life of the star into uh
smaller nuclei uh as it does so so it's
uh going through the core um but it's
also losing energy as it does so and so
um sort of it goes out a certain
distance into the star and it begins to
stall and this has been uh for de
decades the core collapse Supernova
explosion mechanism problem is how do
you get this shock that was launched as
a result of uh the collapse to actually
continue going through the rest of the
star and blow up the star okay so um
this stalled shock issue um and the
answer that a lot of people are looking
at and it's sort of working now uh in
multi-dimensional simulations of core
clap superi is uh you have to rely on
neutrinos heating the material behind
the shock and uh yes so as this neutron
star is forming it's so h and a lot of
uh reactions are happening and you have
a flux of these subatomic particles
called neutrinos coming out of the
neutron star and they're carrying away a
lot of the energy energy of the collapse
and so if you can guess even a little
bit of the neutrino energy to deposit so
for these neutrinos to interact with
with the material that is behind the
Supernova shock and deposit their energy
there uh you can re-energize the shock
and get the explosion to occur and so
this is a nutrino driven mechanism of
core collapse supern noi that uh most
people agree is sort of working and it
is kind of fascinating because we we are
told if we hang out on the wrong street
corners that you know the sun is
emitting neutrinos and they're passing
through our bodies all the time but they
you know they just interact so weakly
that they're relevant uh but this is an
example of where they're super relevant
just because the energies are so high
the densities are so high nutrino doing
a lot of the work yeah it that's amazing
and this is this is actually the thing
that everybody asks me the first time I
say the neutrinos interact because you
know the fun fact that we all grow up
with is neutrinos are passing through
your hand and trillions of them pass
through you and you just never know uh
because they so rarely interact but here
is a the sort of extreme of nature where
the densities and the energies and the
temperatures make it so neutrino matter
interactions become very important and
we saw the neutrinos from Supernova
1987a back uh back in the day that's
right were you uh were you sort of in
the field then is that I was a
undergraduate when that happened I was
not really in the field no but it was
very exciting yeah uh we're not around
yet yeah and we've been waiting ever
since for uh for anything like it but
yeah
whatever I don't know two dozen
neutrinos that were a small number of
nutrino that the number of nutrino is
much smaller than the number of Papers
written about those neutrinos let's put
it that way but we but like you say
we're preparing we have a whole network
ready if another Supernova goes off in
our galaxy or
or so that would be very exciting so do
these neutrinos help us with making
heavier elements do they play a role
there they do play a role so um making
heavier elements uh once you begin to
get to maybe the upper iron group of
elements things are a little bit fuzzier
and once you get Beyond zinc they're
even fuzzier in terms of exactly what's
going on in a core collap Supernova so
for the longest time people thought that
you can make um maybe you can make
everything up to zinc and even Beyond so
your Gallum and geranium and gold and
platinum in a core clap
Supernova but um as we've studied these
more and simulated them more and
actually tried to do the neutrino
physics correctly uh it does not seem as
though they produce any substantial
amounts of the very heavy elements so
core collap suboi uh may be able to
produce uh maybe elements a a little bit
beyond zinc but not not the two too
heavy elements um and neutrinos matter
here because um neutrinos due to as they
get absorbed and emitted they change the
neutron to proton ratio of the material
and the neutron to proton ratio is
something that's really critical um in
terms of making heavier elements because
Beyond a point to make heavy elements
you have to capture
neutrons uh when you have too many
protons in the nucleus it's no longer uh
favorable to be capturing another
Neutron another proton on top of that so
Neutron capture produces a lot of the
truly heavy elements and whether you
have enough neutrons to capture or not
that becomes the question okay so
there's that that it sounds like there's
a lot of uncertainty still in where
sufficiently heavy elements come from I
mean just just so people know what's
going on here iron is uh 26 protons if
I'm remember incorrectly so and that's
where that's like the lowest energy that
that protons and neutrons can settle
into so anything heavier than that you
had to do some work to make it and you
mentioned I guess zinc which is just a
little bit beyond iron yes that's right
so uh if you have a some amount of uh
Neutron Rich material it's possible to
make zinc um but it's it's just uh it's
a lot of balancing a lot of different
reactions uh at the end of the day and
the cross-sections of those re actions
um so you can get a little bit little
bit beyond iring but to truly go much
higher you need because we do go much
higher like lead is like 82 protons or
something like that and that comes from
the universe right yeah zinc is is 30 so
that's that's where I'm stopping um but
even for zinc there's a lot of
uncertainty in terms of where it came
from all of the zinc in the universe but
so should should I think of then like
these iron and iron adjacent elements as
mostly coming from uh core collapse
Supernova uh actually mostly coming from
type 1 a super all right well let's talk
about their role then maybe it's a
combination of uh of these two that
really produces most of the iron group
elements it seems like a weird
coincidence I shouldn't presume both
kinds of supernova the corcap Supernova
and the type 1A Supernova are play a
role in making iron and heavier than
iron elements uh in making iron and
heavier than iron is uh is mostly then
um it it really depends the balance
really depends once you get to nickel
and zinc uh there's a lot of um
uncertainty there some people think that
they have to be made through maybe uh
Neutron capture process like the S
process what is that or okay okay so for
making heavy elements there's two types
of neutron capture processes that people
think about one is um the slow Neutron
capture process or the S process and the
other is the rapid Neutron capture
process the r process and it is what it
kind of sounds like uh basically when
you capture a neutron uh you make an
unstable isotope and then you can
undergo a beta Decay and then uh you end
up with basically uh something that's
one proton heavier a nucleus that's one
proton heavier so if you capture one
Neutron and you undergo beta Decay
you've made a new element that's so bet
Decay is the neutron is decaying into a
proton the the nucleus that has captured
a neutron is decaying into a nucleus
with plus one proton fair enough and so
then it's uh then it's the question of
how quickly can you capture neutrons
versus how quickly is the beta Decay
happen so if you're very slowly
capturing neutrons you kind of stick
close to the stable elements and sort of
have a very nice little ladder that
you're climbing very close to stable
elements and that's the slow Neutron
capture um and this is believed to
happen in sort of lower Mass stars in in
the envelopes of like AGB stars or
something like uh like that so slow
Neutron capture can happen what is an HB
star
uh an asymptotic giant Branch star so
basically uh a a lowish mass star can
still make heavy elements it's just a
completely different process that's
happening the slow Neutron capture
process the rapid Neutron capture
process the r process that's where you
capture a whole bunch of neutrons and
you uh beta Decay back to truly heavy
elements so uh you move very very far
away from the stable elements in terms
of making isotopes that have just uh
have been engorged almost their nuclei
have been engorged with neutrons and
then they're going to undergo beta Decay
back to stability uh to make heavy
elements and this our processes where um
so this is part of my research also so
core collapse supervi and our process in
uh neutron star mergers or neutron star
black hole mergers there you do need
something that's a bit more extreme you
need a a very high uh number of neutrons
um to to enable the ey process basically
C can you just give us a a quick feeling
then how much of the heavy elements we
see around us actually didn't come from
explosions at all but just from like
really uh very persistent grunt work on
the part of these low mass stars yeah so
it goes about half and half I uh in
terms of uh the heavy elements um but it
differs from uh element to element as
well so there are elements that you
can't actually access by doing the S
process and so they are R process only
and there's also something called the P
process um the proton capture process
this is this is the thing you know
people think that this is the broad stru
the periodic table okay it's solved you
know what else is there to figure out
no one is going to come away from this
thinking that but but then the other
thing that you mentioned that I didn't
want to let go by is um that I don't
think everyone uh is familiar with it's
not just exploding stars um it's not
either core collap Supernova or white
dwarfs uh creting from their backgrounds
and exploding there's the this you know
important whole other phenomenon of
coalesence of stars whether it's a
neutron two neutron stars neutron stars
black holes and and maybe again I'm just
thinking people's intuitive picture of
the universe maybe people don't
appreciate how often that happens yeah
yeah the the rates of these events are
another big uncertainty that people are
trying to get at through these
gravitational wave detections so we're
narrowing it down slowly but yes um um
how much heavy element how much of heavy
elements are produced in one Neutron
merger combined with the rates of these
events actually gets you um to present
day abundances of heavy elements yeah so
what exactly happens in the in the
process of two neutron stars merging
yeah so uh the neutron star
binary has formed is the point where I
will start because there's a lot to
understand in terms of binary St Stellar
Evolution as well uh but the binary
exists and the stars are sort of uh
losing some of their um uh losing energy
through gravitational wave radiation and
spiraling towards each other and so at
some point and this will take eons um to
be a vague uh at some point the Stars
will will get so close to each other
that they will begin to rip each other
apart so neutron stars are going to
start tidally disrupting each other and
merge together um and so as this happens
uh some of the material will get thrown
out of the system in mainly the
equatorial region uh through tidal
forces there's also depending upon um um
depending upon kind of the way these
Stars Shear against each other uh
there's going to be additional physical
processes going on there's uh maybe
shock heated ejecta in the polar region
um and so there's there's many ways as
these Stars merge together that they
will throw material out into U into
space and once they merge together what
happens is also uh this post merger
evolution is a big open uncertain uh
area that people are studying and so
depending upon the masses of the neutron
stars you might get a Remnant that's so
massive that it will collapse to form a
black hole and so if you have um
uh if you have a black hole it could
just be a black hole or it could be a
black hole with an accretion disc of
material around it and that accretion
disc also has a lot of important physics
going on with respect to magnetic fields
and turbulence and uh just viscous
Heating and so that accretion dis also
ejects material and it can unbind over a
certain amount of time part of it gets
accreted by the black hole part of it
gets ejected into the U into the Mater
into the space uh and so long story
short the neutrons STS merge together
they form either a black hole a black
hole with an accretion dis or they form
a third possibility where uh depending
upon the masses of the neutron stars and
uh the way angular momentum is being
transported uh it you can end up with a
temporarily stable neutron star and so a
shortlived neutron star that has its own
of processes of mass injection and
eventually collapses to form a black
hole black hole with a disc around it so
there there's a lot of channels through
which um the binary might go after
merging together for the for nucleos
synthesis purposes this whole time
whatever is going on material is being
ejected from the system and all of this
material has different types of
properties conducive to making different
types of elements and again the I
shouldn't say again in this case are
neutron stars 100% neutrons or do they
have an atmosphere where they're protons
as well yeah so they're not 100%
neutrons they're they're largely
neutrons but there's some uh structure
to them as well um and uh I think there
I think it's questionable what
percentage protons are there but there
so I guess a very naive question or
worry that one might have that I can
already see the answer to Is how do you
make nuclei if all you have are neutrons
don't you need protons too but I guess
the decaying takes care that pry quickly
yeah yeah exactly yeah and so it but I
would I would guess less naively that if
I start with just a bunch of neutrons
I'm going to be making Light Elements
again I'm going to start from you know
one or two neutrons at a time so how do
I work my way all the way up to am I
working my way all the way up to very
heavy elements this way you are you are
so um there's I mean this is going to be
too convoluted to get into but the basic
idea is you'll form you'll form elements
up to ion and those will serve as seed
nuclei what you can call a seed nuclei
for Neutron capture to make the even
heavier elements and so that's what's
going on is kind of um um yes you start
out with some um fraction of neutrons
and protons and then you depend upon the
temperatures and the densities and the
interaction rates you form some fraction
of heavier um elements and then there's
still a lot of neutrons remaining and
then you can capture onto those um uh
say iron to to make things like gold um
of course like it's not one to one and
you go through a bunch of intermediate
nuclei uh um it's it's really the when
you think about nuclear synthesis
there's this whole uh set of two body
three body nuclear reactions that are
possible and depending upon the
temperature and the density and the
electron fraction and the entropy the
rates of these reactions are different
and um so you have to you have to but uh
for Neutron capture you can just think
about it in terms of maybe the number of
seed nuclei that are produced and then
uh the neutron to seed
ratio okay so this is
actually again I'm going to admit it's
super helpful I never quite understood
this stuff so as a cosmologist I
understand the Big Bang thing and there
you you make your helium and then you
dilute away so much that there's not
really enough time to do anything else
here it I guess you're saying that
there's enough density and it's it's
packed into enough place that you are
able to get up to iron and once you have
iron in this super Neutron Rich
environment you can just grow right you
can just like you say grab a neutron
beta Decay grab another the neutron and
climb up the ladder yeah climb up the
ladder yeah but that okay I've
oversimplified it because I'm betting
that in fact you have some incredibly
intricate reaction Network that you have
to put on a
computer yes it's thousands and
thousands of Isotopes and you know we
can uh to try to understand them we sit
and make these uh movies where you can
see uh the flux of one element turning
into another element or the Flux Of The
the reaction uh rate basically from one
element to another element and kind of
um and as you watch this movie you'll
see it just goes absolutely
Bonkers um uh in the way things are
interacting of course there's like um
some reactions that are that are way
more favorable than others but there is
a lot going on so truly you need these
thousands and thousands of isotope
networks that you have to solve do you
ever watch one of these movies and think
that that if the mass of the down Quark
had been a little bit different uh it
would have been a very very different
story and this is evidence for the
universe being fine-tuned oh my gosh oh
I don't know about the fine-tuning piece
of it but uh but yes if if uh if the
nuclear properties were different things
might have looked completely different
and that and you know who knows if we'd
be here in this way discuss it but yeah
I this I think about a lot actually
because nuclear astrophysics is truly
special in some ways or this is just my
bias too that it's truly
interdisiplinary it's truly a lot of
trying to figure out uh properties of
nuclei and particles and exactly how um
those will translate into the making of
elements in this whole range of possible
astrophysical conditions um and you know
when I when I'm doing a supernova
simulation yes this is a very large
scale event right like uh a star tens
and of 10 times the mass of the Sun or
20 times the mass of the Sun but it's
coming down to the new trino matter
inter our
actions and that's kind of a funny
connection between uh the scales of
these things think about well there's a
kind of intricacy about it a kind of you
know the the line of stable nucleoids
doesn't go on forever we don't have you
know nucleus that has 10,000 nucleons in
it but it goes up pretty far and it
seems like almost a little delicate if
things were different it wouldn't even
go up that far so I I do you know think
it's at least worth wondering about why
the laws of physics allow for that kind
of richness yeah yeah for sure um and
speaking of this is just something um
you know I get a lot uh people ask
whether there are even heavier elements
in space so we have not found on Earth
yeah maybe and and uh I my answer is
usually like this is a nuclear physics
problem to some extent you know like U
it's it's not just that we're not
looking hard enough uh whether an
element can exist or not is a nuclear
physics problem and so when you get to
truly truly heavy elements then you then
you have to start to figure out I mean
some people think there's
maybe uh at 150 uh protons or something
there's an island of stability where
super heavy nuclei can exist but uh if
those are made somewhere in the universe
then it's the question of can we observe
them and but but I guess even if you
even if they did exist you you may have
already given us a reason to expect that
they're not that abundant right because
ex the elements you make you have to get
there step by step and if there's a gap
in between then it is an island you
can't get to yeah exactly so it's it's
like a truly interdisciplinary kind of
figure out the Nuclear Physics figure
out the environments in which this
Nuclear Physics has to be applied and
then figure out if we can even expect to
tell what is going on just from uh you
know the ways in which astronomers
gather information through photons
through gravitational waves through
neutrinos uh and abundances yeah okay so
I don't want to forget to ask cuz you
mentioned neutron star neutron star
mergers those are obviously very
important but also neutron star black
hole
mergers and again just the super naive
thing is why doesn't the neutron star
fall into the black
hole it's it's not all naive because
that is what happens most of the time
okay good so so it's uh that one's a bit
more um kind of uh we have not really
observed uh nucleus synthesis signature
from those I would say um it's it's kind
of an idea where it's possible to do
nuclear synthesis and the way that would
work is the black hole and the neutron
star Mass would have to be sort of
close-ish to each other so the mass the
mass of the black hole can't be so large
that it swallows up the neutron star
hole um and then uh it also depends on
if the black hole is spinning and um uh
all of these things together and the
equation of state of the neutron star
and so sort of the mass ratio of the
black hole neutron star binary the
equation of state of the neutron star
which is the mass radius relationship of
the neutron star as well as the spin of
the black hole come together to say
whether a black hole can disrupt a
neutron star as it's approaching for
merger or not so part of the neutron
star will get eaten but part of it may
get tidally disrupted and settle in an
accretion just Sur the Black Horn and
there you can make heavier elements
maybe yes and there you can uh over time
uh eject part of the accretion disc and
make heavier so there's a lot of ways to
make heavier elements and I guess the
last one that I know of that we haven't
mentioned yet is through cosmic rays
cosmic rays yes so I I usually think of
cosmic R is producing lithium burum and
Boron okay that's very possible yeah so
they make so so I mean I shouldn't I I
said heavier elements but I meant
heavier than
hydrogen hen yes yes okay so some of our
elements are made by spalation I guess
yeah but not not the super heavy ones
not the ones heavier than iron yeah yeah
that's right so I guess to kind of recap
our our discussion so far it would be um
hydrogen helium and a tiny bit bit of
lithium in the Big Bang uh and then the
rest of the lithium uh bellium and boron
in cosmic rays spallation processes so
this is just where cosmic ray protons
mostly are breaking apart nuclei of
carbon and oxygen in the inter uh Cellar
medium and so then um then there's still
questions so okay lithium maybe some of
it comes from a particular type of uh
eruption called nov and not really so
there's always questions when it comes
to specific elements um where they come
from so okay we've got our big bang
we've got our Cosmic resolation and then
Stars so now you have carbon and oxygen
and nitrogen and everything maybe even
up to
Silicon uh and up to iron and then uh in
the Supernova really uh most of the
Stars core even if it has made Iron
turns into a neutron star or gets once
again broken up so the iron that comes
out in the Supernova is not really um
the iron that was made during life of
the star so explosive nuclear synthesis
right burning of silicon to iron happens
burning of oxygen to to Silicon these
kind of things and so you have the ion
group of elements so now you've done
with big bang cosmic rays stars and
supery maybe everything up to iron and
then it's the question is okay what now
and there this s process and low mass
stars uh does part of the creation of uh
elements heavier than iron and then our
processed so these Neutron mergers and
neutron black hole mergers maybe other
kinds of super noi it's really not super
super solved um as a problem so um these
types of events create the rest and it
would be remiss not to mention that we
have been trying to create humans have
been trying to create uh elements too
and so some of the elements are are are
basically human made elements like burum
where I'm sitting right now in Berkeley
was created here so and okay I guess I
guess the the other thing I wanted to
help our listeners with is uh a feeling
of scale I mean both in terms of um a
supernova explosion where a lot of these
are made I guess uh let's include is it
sorry is it correct to include these
neutron star merger events in the world
of super or are they separate things um
they are kind of their own thing but I
think it's fine to include them in in
the sense that it's sort of a dynamic
event that's okay big
explosions yeah so these big explosions
I would I would tend to think of as
being located somewhere in the Galaxy or
someplace like that how efficient are
they at spreading all these heavier
elements across a Galaxy yeah that's
another another sort of area of study
almost so there are
relationships that people have tried to
derive um depending on how much energy
is output in a
supernova uh and how much of the
material it can mix in so the Supernova
ejecta will mix in and so there are
relationships so uh if you have a very
energetic this is might be intuitive if
you have a super energetic explosion you
can just uh mix the that you've ejected
way farther out than if you have a lower
energy explosion and so um uh that kind
of is this field of Galactic chemical
Evolution where people try to figure out
if a supernova goes off uh you know if
10 Supernova go off in all these parts
of this galaxy what does a galaxy look
like uh down the line and I guess this
is also should be obvious but maybe
there are some details that are
interesting here on Earth it seems like
we have a lot of iron we even have
things like copper and and nickel and
things like that so yeah did these
mostly come from exploding Stars one way
or the other yes yes that's right and so
then once you start thinking about the
Earth itself uh it gets a bit messy in
terms of now you have to think about you
know the planets formation and and so on
uh the when I think about the
composition of the solar system or when
I say composition of the solar system
and trying to understand that that
really means composition of the
Sun the planets don't matter basically
yeah because all all of the mass uh in
the solar system is mainly sitting in
the sun and so um for the Earth then the
geological processes and things like
that being into matter as well okay and
like in terms of deciding in which layer
of the Earth various elements not in
terms of producing new elements really
right yeah and uh well we we can wrap up
with I do want to mention again I did
mention the intro but I'll mention again
your Tik Tock Series where you're
explaining some of this uh in a
completely different medium um but one
of the fun things is you not only
explain the nuclear astrophysics and the
uh our process s process stuff but every
element kind of tells a story right and
you you certainly given yourself the
task of having fun things to say about
strong and Boron and and things like
that I mean maybe you can just share
with us a couple fun things about your
favorite elements oh wow yes so I kicked
off this series which is called Stardust
and posting it on Tik Tok and also on
YouTube with
strontium um and part of the motivation
was because there was in 2017 a
detection of a neutron St merger and the
light from a neutron St merger um and in
that light one of the elements that
astronomers have confidently detected
again there's arguments of course around
every single thing in astronomy uh but
is the element strontium and so I I was
thinking about strontium that year a lot
and it started popping up in places that
you wouldn't uh usually as an astronomer
think about so for example there's uh
marine organisms that make their
skeletons out of strontium sulfat and
okay I did not know that strontium
Isotopes can tell you uh what region a
wine came from so there's varying levels
of strontium Isotopes in the soil in
different parts of the earth and when uh
plants grow or an animal like a mammoth
eats uh those strontium uh isotope
ratios get encoded in the grapes for
example uh when you make wine out of
those grapes uh there's the strum so um
it's it's a lot of uh Fields uh that you
wouldn't even think about use these
Isotopes so wine fra can be prevented by
looking at strum isotope ratios in your
wine um but I would say uh my favorite
one is how you can figure out the region
in which a woolly mammoth live by
looking at the the Tusk of the mammoth
and the layers in the Tusk and the
strontium Isotopes ratios encoded in
those layers so Mammoth tusks grow in
layers like tree rings almost and so um
every layer encodes the ratio uh of
Isotopes from the region in which the
mammoth was living and eating what is it
specifically about strontium that makes
that so useful rather than some other
element oh yes so strontium um and I
believe rubidium there's a
particular
relationship um in the way these
elements Decay so there there's two
stable isotopes I'll have to look at the
details because I don't remember off the
top of my head but there's uh some sort
of relationship between um the stable
isotopes of strontium and the way the
decay of other Isotopes forms those that
makes it a good Tracer of U time and
region and things like that okay so
something that
just and things like that yeah so I
guess the final question then is this
leads on from that um you already
mentioned how
interdisciplinary the field is like if
if there's a young person here who wants
to become a nuclear astrophysicist uh
what is included in the list of things
you have to know I mean it sounds like
there's some particle physics there's
astrophysics there's
uh I mean Nuclear Physics pretty
obviously and maybe some other things
I'm not even thinking of you know I'll
tell you what first drew me into nuclear
astrophysics and it was listening to a
talk where somebody was describing their
Supernova
simulation and basically it turns out
that to correctly understand a supernova
explosion and this is true of very many
things but especially in this case it it
becomes very obvious um you need to
understand basically all of the types of
physics that that exist so you need
general relativity you need uh Nuclear
Physics so you actually need to
understand like things like Quantum uh
as well and um then of course it's uh
radiation and radiation transport this
kind of thing and so
electromagnetism as well so it it kind
of just brings everything together into
this very complex messy system and now
you're trying to extract information out
of it um about how stars live and die as
well as how uh dense matter Works uh
conditions that are not uh that we're
not able to access here on Earth what do
you have a specific research goal that
you're hoping comes true over the next
number of years like is there a burning
question you most want to answer yes
there's two so one of the things I'm
really trying to understand um are the
transients that come from Neutron St
mergers so so what I mean by that is
there's light that is produced when a
neutron Sur merger makes heavy elements
uh those elements Decay and the
radioactive decay of those elements
Powers um a light uh a signal basically
basically and it's called the kilonova
signal similar to a supernova just um
for the merger case and to truly
understand how kovi work you really have
to get a handle on every single way a
merger could produce material the
properties of the of that material and
then uh how photons travel through that
material and so this very last piece of
doing the multi-dimensional radiative
transfer calculation sorry for all the
all thear words but that is what I'm
trying to do and the goal is to really
figure out are neutrons surgers the only
source of uh our process elements is is
is this truly the only site where rapid
Neutron capture happens or needs to
happen to
explain um the abundances of these heavy
elements in the universe um my guess
would be probably no but it would be it
would be good to uh understand and then
s from from in the opposite direction uh
from the core collab Supernova side I
want to try to understand the properties
of um of the first stars for example so
it's very difficult to make connections
from um a star that's maybe 20 solar
masses all the way to what kind of
elements uh exactly what amounts of
elements It produced and the type of
light curve that you should see um we
don't even know if it should necessarily
explode or not so this is one of the big
open questions is like uh which stars
explode and which don't and so hopefully
by understanding the chemical signatures
of of explosions I can try to work
towards understanding the properties of
the stars that exploded themselves well
that should keep you busy for a while I
like that I won't I won't keep you here
any longer with all that on the plate so
San kernes thanks you so much for being
on the mindcap podcast thank you this is
uh really really
[Music]
fun
w